An accusation commonly thrown at trap lives online
is that because they make money,
or a small amount of money in this case online,
then therefore they are truly not traditional
and they are just cosplaying
being traditional. People like Anna here comment these things
because they hear other creators on other platforms
parrot these talking points
that are just not true. Cause most people are taught,
especially women are taught
that women have always been borrowed from the workforce
because feminism has been such a great thing.
Women can now work.
But women have historically always worked in some form.
Now I'm not saying it's always been sunshine and roses for women
in history, cause we know that's not true.
Women used to be borders, they used to run out properties,
be drink workers, selling things at market.
And other skilled crafts like sewing.
Really earning an income from home or even outside the home
is in line with traditional values.
The main difference today, however,
is that work is no longer centered around the home,
which thanks to the Industrial Revolution,
has caused a plethora of problems for both men and women.
The big part of the traditional movement
is re centering our focus on the home,
the main priority in our life.
And creating productive households that generated income
is part of that.